the gyro can experience smash so many
people there was so many guys like that
that fought in Japan where they have
these freak shows I mean crazy I saw one
the other day like that thing we're like
a like a woman and her nipples are just
like almost like like combs and then
it's like the game shows like these guys
are just like put their fingers and that
is wild I mean there's just so many wild
things in Japan like you can see it's
gnarly bro well they are the birth of a
lot of those crazy game shows and then I
mean a lot of the game shows like even
Fear Factor like that have even happened
if it wasn't for the crazy Japanese
shows oh what's in the water over there
to make him think like that and we were
saying they were oppressed but it's also
I mean why they so repressed have you
ever seen bazooka man uhh
Zuka man was a Japanese game show where
a guy with a bazooka which show up at
people's houses okay like a real live
bazooka like with like missile in bed
okay be in bed sleeping and bazooka man
would shoot the bazooka at your wall
above your head while you're asleep this
is a real film it what they're filming
this new explodes like your head shoots
a rocket launcher through your [ __ ]
wall boom and this guy's yeah they wake
up [ __ ] screaming there's a hole in
the wall above the head and the audience
in Japan's like hahahahahaha you can
find it you can find the videos bruh
Jamie Oh find it what is that that's a
real okay maybe Rocket Man okay so I
pretty sure was bazooka man and it's a
real rocket whatever it is it's firing
out of a cannon that's on his shoulders
and it's hitting the wall that explodes
right Google Japanese game show where
they blow up wall behind I mean how do
you have like a heart attack and like
when you wake up like you get asleep
yeah usually could yeah so I'm saying I
mean you must like sound like a death
warrant before you uh for sure you can
definitely a heart attack though Jesus
unless it's like dead asleep and they
all signed up for this is all consensual
basically okay face down I don't think
they signed up for it I think they're
just allowed to do stuff like that and
they give you money okay if you survive
right well I don't think they have the
same concept of lawsuits that we do over
here
okay you got it oh no no I'm my way to
finding it though I found one this is
called the bum show where girls would
put their bum in a hole and a guy would
kiss it he's either ass yeah basically
right on TV hmm okay can't comment on
that one they have different ways of
living they really do have a different
style can't hate it can't be hating on
them Jesus is it China or Japan where
they have like they have like these
crazy work hours right like like like
factory workers you know just like the
whole economy is just like work all the
time and they have bending machines
where you can just like pocket [ __ ]
basically oh yeah it's like the guys
were just like they're yeah they'll just
use those things they'll toss them oh
and just go back to work oh yeah Wow I
want to say it's that's Japan I could be
one they both have they're both known
for their work yeah ours right you know
so like sex just isn't a part of the
other routine yeah I was watching some
documentary on or reading something
rather on wall way mm-hmm I'm always
this Chinese phone company and the guy
had a bed underneath his desk his
craziest image he's in his cubicle and
his stuff is above him and he's got a
bed laid out under his cubicle and he's
asleep was like glasses at work
exhausted it's like a 18 hour day
probably yeah
make it cell phone so we could take
selfies